next July the Maracana stadium in Rio
will erupt at the final of the 2014
World Cup
which teams will face off there busty
hey Bastian come here I have a riddle
for you will Germany finally win the big
prize again
or will the legendary trophy be raised
by the hosts Brazilians are crazy about
football which involve they certainly
are the steady hand in the cellar Sal
midfield should know in Brazil the
passion starts in the cradle the middle
Isaac the first thing parents say when
the boys born is he's gonna play for the
silicide everyone's dreaming six months
before the world cup finals begin
writers fans players
kickoff takes a look at the pain prayers
and laughter of the upcoming World Cup
with just six months left until the
world cup finals kick-off set off on the
road to Rio and we found the country's
youngsters in a confident mood Brazil is
gonna win it'll be a walkover from the
seller so I'll cry tears of joy just
around the corner it's still all about
the brazilian league Vasco da Gama our
club rich in history is fighting to
escape relegation we meet some fans
waiting for them to take on Santos of
America Mia welcome to forces U of M we
meet up here three to four hours before
every match and it's always a great
party I'll face I would even say most of
the fans here are locals from the city's
poor and northern districts for surge of
em was set up over 40 years ago it's
more a family than a fan club and it's
also always been political in dollar fee
I've always torn between my social
conscience and my love of football on
the one hand the world cup is a
fantastic chance for Brazil to present
its best sign to the world on the other
it's clear that the country's poor won't
be invited to the world cup party the
prices are too high how can you spend
350 million euros for a stadium it's
absurd people are right to protest what
we need our hospitals and schools
tens of thousands of Brazilians have
vented their anger about that cost of
the tournament the government is
spending some nine billion euros of
taxpayers money to put on the world cup
finals including three billion for new
stadiums alone professor Orlando sandals
would prefer more sustainable investment
the prominent critic sees the world cup
as more of a curse than a blessing I
think that the protests will continue
because the problems haven't been solved
the projects the World Campus spawned
continue to have a negative impact on
the lives of our citizens and especially
on the lives of the poor he'll be back
tues service comunidad swabs Brazil's
chief World Cup organizer Ricardo trotty
has been given 300 million euros and a
free hand by FIFA he says the protests
are the responsibility of Brazilian
authorities as they did during the
Confederations Cup together if the
public security force from the state and
the city they keep the protesters far
from the station and inside the station
we have an excellent a spectacle and
that's the guarantee that they they gave
to FIFA in 2007 in northern real the
protest seemed a million miles away just
two hours to kick off time to head to
the stadium
the route takes the members of forces
all them to an area that most of next
year's World Cup visitors certainly
won't see 600,000 foreign tourists are
expected to attend the tournament but
they'll spend most of their time in the
southern parts of the city close to the
city's famous cover cabana and ipanema
beaches Matthias and his friends are
looking forward to a game or two with
some foreign visitors amazing forsythias
al Brazil is the benchmark for football
feelings but we also have a lot more to
offer the world cup will be a great
celebration of soccer but at the same
time we'll be able to show that there's
a lot more to discover here what's
raising awareness and visitors will pay
for the privilege it's expected each
tourists will spend about three hundred
euros a day in Rio everyone is hoping to
profit including beach hawker Felipe
Souza he's already figured out how he'll
spend the extra cash I'm gonna buy a
moped in a house I don't want to rent
anymore that's my dream I'm able to live
while Felipe does one more round there's
just an hour before the game starts back
at the Maracana modernizing the
legendary stadium costs 350 million
euros three times more than originally
budgeted and where police often clashed
with rowdy fans more than a thousand
stewards are on duty to help spectators
there's no comparing it to the old days
now it's safe you can bring your kids I
would it's nice comfortable and well
organized fantastic let's go
forcer jovem arrived half an hour before
kickoff well in time for the action to
begin
Fosco have problems from the opening
whistle and sent us quickly go up to nil
the frustration is poppable
then the scope pull one back and the
south stand goes wild
oh god that's what no job at moments
like these it feels just like the old
days especially because tickets for
today's match cost only around three
euros the same as before the renovations
it's a close to capacity crowd but says
the facelift the private sector
organizer often charges 30 euros and
upwards that's far more than most fans
can afford
it's a big issue for football journalist
Rica peroni on his radio chat show fans
can call him to take part in the live
show prices that are one hundred fifty
percent higher than they were for the
final of the Copa Libertadores that's
insane what are they thinking that only
is talking about the record prices for
tickets to the final of the Copa do
Brasil they start at 80 euros and that's
a huge sum for most Brazilians put your
ball in Brazil football has an important
social function in the stadium's there's
no rich or poor or white or black
categories like that don't exist there
everyone hugs each other everyone's
equal but if it gets too expensive the
poor won't be able to go anymore the
atmosphere in the stadiums will be
totally different Louie was my spa but
it was if that happens then the world
cup will be bad for Brazil's Parvati see
you in Peru Brazil back at the Maracana
Vasco have equalized and hang on for a
tool drawer
one point can't check off the threat of
relegation but at least there are the
world cup finals to look forward to
playing at a world cup is what every
player dreams of German clubs could be
richly represented this time here is
kickoffs Bundesliga World Cup 11
featuring warriors and Mavericks stars
and a couple of surprises thrown in in
goal for example we have an Australian
following the retirement of beloved
veteran Mark Schwarzer Mitchell Langerak
is tipped to become the Socceroos number
one he might only be second choice at
Dortmund but this man is no toothless
watchdog wake up Johann Georg the
Switzerland defender will be hoping to
avoid gaps like this recent own goal at
his club Hamburg his bad luck was
compounded by a groin injury a week
later fortunately judo seems to know how
to relax and get fully fit to represent
his country in Brazil
one man who always has been a rock in
defenses Daniel Pemberton all one metre
97 of him his explosive power has left
its mark on the oddball to the 35 year
olds energy and experience will be
crucial as Belgium seek to live up to
their growing reputation Germany will be
among the big-name favorites of course
and those names don't get any bigger
than skipper Philipp Lahm LOM is mr.
dependable weather at right-back or a
holding midfielder he's still looking
for his first silverware with the German
national team however not least to keep
those demanding young fans happy between
hubby javi martinez is the third Bayern
player in our world cup 11 he won the
treble in his first season in Munich
after playing only a minor role in
Spain's World and European triumphs in
twenty ten and twenty twelve the
midfielder has his heart set on a
first-team place in Brazil Japan would
love nothing more than to bring home a
first world cup title that's a tall
order indeed even harnessing the superb
ball skills shown by Frank Fritz Takashi
anyway out on the wing but it never
hurts to dream this decorated Bundesliga
warrior has dreams of his own chaka
midfielder kevin-prince boateng will be
playing for ghana does he have just the
right combination of aggression and
leadership qualities after the Black
Stars 6-1 win over Egypt in the
qualifying rounds we expect boa tang and
Ghana to rock the boat in Rio Rafael
fonda fought has lived for football all
his life so far the Dutch superstar and
Hamburg playmaker has collected 107 caps
for the arancia definitely a member of
our dream 11
up front let's add Boy Wonder heung-min
son the 21 year old striker is in top
form at labor kuzin and he has a huge
number of fans in his home country of
South Korea alongside him we would place
gold machine vedad ibisevic he's put in
84 Stuttgart so far this Belinda's liga
campaign and is one of five
internationals from the bosnia
herzegovina team to play in the top
german league and there's one last slot
on our road to Rio Bundesliga
international dream team definitely
dedicated to this week's guest on
kickoff Luis Gustavo has already landed
at birth in Brazil vault sports man in
the middle is a key player for the
cellar sow the holding midfielder is
also a serious scoring threat up front
so here's a proper look at kickoffs
World Cup 11 all Bundesliga players
looking to make their mark in Brazil
next summer
yes i saw one dear white have been
convulsed book I've come to bull spoke
to meet my competitor Luis Gustavo he's
one of two Brazilians in the Bundesliga
who have a good chance of playing in the
world cup finals but it's been a long
hard slog to get this far Gustavo's
mother died when he was just 16 shortly
after he moved to the other side of
Brazil to play for al agua no age 19 he
came to Hoffenheim as they made their
ascent into the Bundesliga he cemented
his reputation as a fiery defensive
midfielder at Bayern before signing for
vaults Borg in the summer of 2013
certain are doing a saloon temporada
Hoffenheim arrive koenig LEDs my
cosmetology kyocera malevolence a
Bundesliga he was a lame revenue Bruce
Willis poquoson llamado de nada SMS was
incorrect not immediately nada yo st.
achievers who me go SMP jejeje no no
michi plus questbridge if you could I
Jesuit msot he saved ye pehla stiffy
food ads as veg pulao pool blah de las
cosas contest Navy denied on the entire
company I differential Prokhorov Fazio
matra Baloo Miller [ __ ] really yes
really super gone he's gone arguments I
was thinking was oh god is key here is a
new theory goddess intermediate mi
ultima carta SS squeeze my SS hola dokie
here okay he'll mention a faster deeper
said a honky-tonk our using G so at the
familia adagio dodging Alagoas got it
dis ya vendi Miyazaki 85 millimeter nope
i simply battalion more into food
momentum meo na vonas familiar story
you're simply for me to live in
dependence in desi pickin y cuando fibra
prologo SE puede perder mohammadreza
bastard tanisha gay live Davaris it was
a California Road on Angie gucci a
profiler can simply drop
but I do evilly evolve videocon calluses
boston MA suffice treason stays on gmail
mood to bones no Hoffenheim yeah you
present a growl in the Pro Mod Club
thalamus and possessing SF four
fundamental was established a solution
brasileiro see insane sainte-beuve the
mia i meant responsible by a unique few
free undos fat or skinny Oh dawn when
Tasha ghana na sila so he ferrando is
done they made me to win two bones and
put down life as a consigue desk ii
keenay mochi me chama Sagira i doona
pisces malaysia much Phillies movoto la
conquista kassandra's lira Kobus
conference she gonna buy in yo tenedor
pep guardiola pre video dont you gotta
do is keep living contenidos not
obscured improve Assad dumped in 10 days
I really cut down things to us with
loads of here neck when I differential
on Tina door to the pocket em co scale
entrado containment Olaf cibo moon to
mez mita must run a convoy you muneca to
immense VARs amigos compañeros see Burke
meghna cause convo tar oh hey no VAR
contrato cigar polarizes no tsukuyomi
future hecho mas cada auntie sue
historico de un ting tang soo esto era
de vida y am ia pon de sempre few AC
Chicago ma ma go no Cara MA go MA go no
no Chico carmo intensive austere tenses
Dez's osos osos your Ypres ferry oppo
por otro por lo Tuesday Jonah doors yo
tenki quieres pitamah necesita el aviso
mais à des acontece cuidas que agente
Nunes Perine da paz de que vosotros co
campione where opio payload SNP Mirko
cada Bundesliga so que la copa do mundo
no car no no porque usted achieves a qui
tam bene 10 grands EO Godot sectomy own
vagin adios otras dos y
sunday in tow un progetto bono chingkuo
got Americans nanas lso meizu principado
to do no no fue limp raucous Oprah yoga
fuiste mi pelo proposed do clue be in
Shigar consta a constable a Chivas que
son bien visuals popova brasilero Oppo
povo is trans air chief Oprah capo do
mundo que le pas des peres do brasil
arroz con mucho SI NOS que es que se
você é que quisiera que por brasilera
fanatico football concert SI rezvani
gaya tsukamoto commento aspetti sofas
dia fest dimelo fama possible credit to
key to the kia contest no brasil my a
trap a la derecha copa de moon rookie
Todd sub judice to the specialist atom
suit coin potentials a sumo competes on
amazon or spies aqui todo pave SI todo
mundo algebra Sabha positing in meadow
oh my preoccupation Tversky da Vinci
interns condo lame Brian no come kiss
attracts a caponata k to do mundo lame
Bree key Neymar Joe go to scar jogo mais
no valen blocking el mejor pasado they
keep picking limpo I the king though
putting the person who posses hurts no
Carlos otra good dishes what's fuzzy on
killing Cooper bro hasta que yo kefka
ball that ye desh overly cochino as you
done killed about a feeling for the part
DC still a DC disc impunity
germany vs brazil one of the classic
fixtures in international football but
at this match on a local artificial
pitch in frankfurt you'll search in vain
for the likes of Neymar or ism the match
will be battled out between teams of
writers representing the two great
footballing nations the visitors are out
of their elements here in terms of both
wet weather and performance they're
representing a nation where football has
been elevated to an art form jogo bonito
the beautiful game and it's a game at
which Brazil has been world champions a
record five times Pepe was in two of
those World Cup winning teams in 1958
and 62 today he's coach of the Brazilian
literary squad Wonderland obras you the
first thing parents will say when a
child is born is he'll play for brazil
monday that says a lot about the
importance of the game for the country
feel football brazil represent time we
talk with the game was introduced to the
country by charles miller a brazilian of
British descent he brought two footballs
in a rule book with him on his return
from England in 1894 just one year later
the first official match on Brazilian
soil a team representing the Sao Paulo
railway company 142 against the city
gasworks the rest is history football
has become an integral part of Brazil's
identity and national pride
this year's Frankfurt Book Fair have
Brazilian writers in the spotlight we
went looking for literary insights into
the country's obsession with football
one of the hot books at the fair was
this anthology of 16 football related
stories from Brazil covering the magic
and the disappointment that includes
personal insights from the game as it's
played on the streets traditionally
football was not celebrated greatly in
Brazilian literature but many of the
stories reveal how difficult it has
always been to ignore sack Romania in
the country Adriana lisboa story
references her experiences growing up
the chubby girl and her friend took the
ball and went outside they'd been on the
street for half an hour and were kicking
the ball about when the two boys turned
up they leaned against the street lamp
the goal squinted at them out of the
corners of their eyes thrust forward
their breasts and laughed in a strategic
attempt to appear seductive the long
legged ones football talent became
representative of everything that is
beautiful and desirable then the chubby
one gave the ball a hard kick and it
landed exactly where both girls wanted
it to be at the boys feet yet they with
utter insolence and no trace of timidity
simply snatched it up and ran down the
street
where's our skating we've talked the
fascinating thing for me is the talent
for improvisation that has always
distinguished our big players the
ability to conjure up great moments and
tricky situations there have been so
many such moments in the history of
brazilian football times do change of
course but for us football still
represents something innocent simple and
spontaneous we see it as a form of art
do you know says that you generally bad
brothers are sound raftery and on that
front few players can match the artistry
of the football world's first superstar
Pele regarded as the ultimate Brazilian
footballer and for Pepe and many others
the greatest player of the 20th century
killers in yo the popular cartoon
character the 70s and 80s based on young
Pele is now making a triumphant comeback
its creator famous brazilian cartoonist
Mauricio D'Souza remembers the living
legends original reaction will be the
only thing I brought him a sketch of a
Latino like this one here well thank you
he said no I thought you were gonna draw
me as a superhero super hot laughter so
I told him too short to his children for
you and let them decide whether they
prefer his or the superhero when he came
back the next day he just said okay you
knew that go for this version hello oh
well since I vehicle is he was courteous
like he hella Zeno himself became a huge
star in Brazil in a series of adventures
where he'd solve problems with the ball
at his feet nearly came from a poor
background but had an aim he was totally
committed training till he dropped until
he made it as a professional woman
assist was soo and he became the
greatest player of all time that's why
he represents Brazil land full of
opportunities for everyone who has a
dream or a goal and is prepared to work
for it okay having that determination in
Brazil is already on the road to success
mom esta é is what America today is
really
back at the International writers match
the winner this time around is Germany
the hosts were 91 run away victors
although the Brazilians could at least
site jet lag it was all smiles and
signatures afterwards though coach Pepe
is far more confident about Brazil's
chances at the real thing when hosting
the World Cup next year yes I was 15 the
last time the world cup was in Brazil in
nineteen fifty I was there and for me
Brazil are the favourites next year the
main thing is that they play a good
tournament
the 1950 world cup in brazil left deep
wounds in the country's collective
football psyche the seller South lost in
the final in maracanã stadium will this
world cup see closure every player
dreams of playing in the World Cup and
for us Brazilians it will be even more
special because it's happening in our
country I'm naive
una mirada he began teaching my devil
will give you Jim what a brother
game on this arrow
two of us I dream a lot for Buster's
Oh